we've been sneaking up on this question
all over the place let me ask the big
ridiculous question what is the meaning
of life
wow
um
the meaning of life
yeah i don't know i mean that i've never
really understood that question when you
say meeting crisis
you're you're saying that there is
a search for a kind of
experience that's
could be described as fulfillment as
like the ah like the aha moment of just
like joy and
maybe when you see something beautiful
or maybe you have created something
beautiful that experience that you get
it feels like
it all makes sense
so some of that is just chemicals coming
together in your mind and all kinds of
things
but
it seems like we're building a
sophisticated
uh collective intelligence that's
providing meaning in all kinds of ways
it's it's members
and
it
there's a theme to that meaning so for
for a lot of history i think
faith
played an important role uh faith in god
as a religion
i think uh technology in the modern era
is kind of serving a little bit of a
source of meaning for people like
innovation of different kinds
i think the old school
things of love
and the basics of just being good at
stuff
but
you were a physicist
so there's a desire to say okay yeah but
these seem to be like symptoms of
something deeper
right like why little meaning what's
capital m yeah what's capital i'm
meaning
why are we reaching for order when there
is excess of energy
i don't know if i can answer the why
any why that i come up with i think is
going to be
um
i i'd have to think about that a little
more maybe maybe get back to you on that
but i will say this
um we do look at the world through
a traditional i think most people look
at the world through what i would say is
a subject object kind of a metaphysical
lens that we have our own subjectivity
and then there's
there's all of these
object things that are not us so i'm i'm
me and this is these things are not me
right and i'm interacting with them i'm
doing things to them
but a different view of the world that
looks at it as much more connected
that realizes oh i'm
i'm really
quite embedded in a soup of other things
and i'm simply
um almost like a standing wave pattern
of different things right
um so when you look at the world in that
kind of connected sense i i've recently
taken
a shine to this particular thought
experiment which is
what if it was the case
that
everything that we touch with our hands
that we pay attention to that we
actually give intimacy to
what if there's actually
you know all all the mumbo jumbo like
you know
people with the magnetic healing
crystals and all this other kind of
stuff and quantum energy stuff
what if that was a thing
what if when you literally when your
hand touches an object
when you really look at something and
you concentrate you focus on it and you
really give it attention
you actually give it there is some
physical residue
of something a part of you
a bit of your life force that goes into
it
okay now this is of course completely
mumbo jumbo stuff this is not like i
don't actually think this is real but
let's do the thought experiment what if
it was
what if there actually was
some quantum magnetic crystal and you
know energy field thing that just by
touching this can this can has
changed a little bit somehow
and it's not much
unless you put a lot into it and you
touch it all the time like your phone
right
these things gained they gave meaning to
you a little bit
um
but what if there's something
that technical objects the phone is a
technical object it does not really
receive
attention or intimacy and then allow
itself to be transformed by it
but if it's a piece of wood if it's the
handle of a knife that your mother used
for 20 years to make dinner for you
right what if it's
a keyboard that you banged out your
world transforming software library on
these are technical objects and these
are physical objects but
somehow there's something to them we
feel an attraction to these objects as
if we have imbued them with life energy
yeah right so if you walk that thought
experiment through what happens when we
touch another person when we hug them
when we hold them
and it
the the reason this ties into my answer
for your question is that um
there's
if there is such a thing if we were to
hypothesize uh you know hypothetically
it's such a thing
um
it could be that
the purpose of our lives
is to imbue as many things with that
love as possible
that's a that's a beautiful answer and a
beautiful way to end it peter uh you're
an incredible person thank you spanning
so much in the space of engineering
and in the space of philosophy
i
i'm uh really proud to be living in the
same city
and
i'm really grateful that you would spend
your valuable time with me today thank
you well thank you i appreciate the
opportunity to speak with you
you